Asalam alaikum doctor. Welcome to
Indonesia. Welcome to Malang. I already
follow you since two days ago in solo.
But I just have uh my mind today in this
morning. I just pop up in my mind. I
want to ask about Genesis 21.
>> Can I have your name sister? Your
profession?
>> My name is Inan and I'm a flight
attendant.
I want to ask about Genesis 21 verse 20
about Ishmael.
So this is one of the topic that's
become one of the debated topic between
uh Christian and Muslim
and I already asked about this two
kodoni
but I just want to know maybe you have a
different answer.
So about Genesis 20 verse 21 verse 20
but I just check in the English version
the first is just talk about God was
with the boy as he grew up he live in
the desert and become an archer
so in the English version it doesn't
state is he grew up in Bashaba or in
Paran desert
but in Indonesian version
it state that uh he grew up in Bersea
and then stay in Paran desert with his
mother Hagar.
So I ever discussed this with my
non-Muslim friend and he said no Hagar
is
uh stay and live in Bashba not in Pan
because in here it's not really confirm
that he grew up in Bashba or Paran.
So that's just one of the topic that
come out in my mind today. Thank you.
Sister, which verse are you referring
to?
>> Genesis chapter 21. Which verse?
>> Uh verse 20.
>> Genesis 21. Chapter 21 verse 20.
>> 20. Verse 20 or verse 120.
>> Genesis 21.
>> Chapter 21 verse number
>> 20.
>> Yeah. 21. And then first two.
>> Okay. What's the
So what's your main question? So I just
want to know uh
is Hagar and Ismael's
they grew up in Basha desert or in Pan
because in Indonesian person it doesn't
state where they grew up. It just state
that in the end they stay in Paran
desert.
So the Bible doesn't mention where they
stayed. So how will I comment on that
sister?
>> Yeah. Yes sir.
>> What you have to understand that many a
time what is mentioned in the Quran and
the Bible what is not even if I come to
know what difference will it make in my
faith?
>> Um
>> sister what difference will make in your
faith if you come to know where they
have grown up?
>> Uh because I ever discussed it with
Kodoni.
uh it's correlated with the when Ibraim
make a agreement in Bashaba.
>> M
>> so it's become like a debated topic
between Muslim and Christian is Ibraim
stay with Hagar or with
uh Sah. Yeah because
>> you want to know that who did he stay
with
>> Hagar or Sara? Yeah, because uh I got
the version
>> uh Sara is
she sorry
so she passed
so she died
in another city is it I'm not sure so
it's become like debated between
Christian and Muslim no both were wives
of Ibraimam Hagar and Sarah both were
wives
S also is a wife and hag is also a wife.
So what is the debate about? I don't
understand.
>> Uh because in Christian
>> we always thought that Ibraim stay with
Sah
but
uh Koni ever said to me that because
Ibrahim make agreement in Basha
>> and Sif Hagar and Ismael grew up and
live in Bashba. So it means Ibraim live
together with Hagar not with Sarah and
it's become like
>> it is depending initially of course the
first wife was S. So first part of the
life he lived with Sara after he married
Hager lived with Hagar also.
>> So what is the difference I don't
understand.
>> He lived with S initially.
>> Mhm.
>> Later on he married Hagar.
>> Correct.
>> He they lived with Hagar also.
>> Mhm. Then he left Hagar and Makkah then
left her. So different times of life he
lived with different people. So where is
the problem?
>> In different part of his life he lived
with different wives.
>> Uh yeah because uh I've got the Bible
version.
Sorry.
Oh yeah. I got the Bible version. Sara
is died and been
uh in Hebron near Kahan.
So we've been told that uh by Kodoni. So
actually
um
Ibraim is stay with Hagar not with Sah.
So just want to know
>> after Sah died how can he stay with
Sarah?
>> Sorry. After Sara died, how can he stay
with Sarah?
>> No, I mean uh Kodoni said that Ibrahim
not stay with Sara because Tara is stay
different place with Ibraim.
>> Yeah.
>> No, but what different does it make?
>> Um yeah because in
>> what difference does it make in your
faith or my faith? Yeah,
>> we believe that both are wives of
Ibraham
and he lived with both at certain times.
So where is the where is your logic that
what different does it make?
>> Does Ibrahimam become a lesser prophet?
No.
>> Um because uh we always thought that
Ibrahim stay together with Sarah.
>> What difference? I'm asking you what
different does it make in your faith?
And
>> my question is that does Ibraimam become
a lesser prophet or a better prophet?
No.
>> So if we discuss things which makes a
difference like someone asked me what
was the name of Musa Alisam's mother?
I'm going to research. What difference
going to make to me?
You understand now? I know about what's
the name I do research but does it
benefit me? Certain research benefits in
your faith. Certain research is only
academic. I am a D. I do research in
that helps me in doing dawa. Correct? I
have read the Bible. I've read the
Quran. So I do more research on things
that I can make a person make a
difference in his faith.
But there are certain questions like
someone asked me do you know the name of
the mother of Musa Alisam?
No research on it. I said what different
does it make?
Do you understand? So we do research on
things in which it makes a difference in
our faith and life. Some research
doesn't take you anywhere. Hope that
answers the question.